match de fin de saison au gymnase
chastagner les chocs ce dell en coiffe
ronde ce dimanche 14 avril
asnières pour la dernière journée du
championnat de nationale 4 après une
entame de match convaincante ponctuée
par deux buts les visiteurs reviennent
au score juste avant la mi-temps 2-1 à
la pause on n'a pas trop joué on n'a pas
trop forcé on a voulu on n'a pas
vraiment joué en fait clairement on à
suzhou est clairement pas de pression
particulière on savait qu'on était quand
on rester en nationale iv c'était un
match de classement
je pense qu'on la prenne un peu en
dilettante au retour des vestiaires les
visiteurs égalisent rapidement à
détonateur pour elle en cours
les vagues offensives élan courtoise
déferlent sur le but d'asnières le choc
s'ils l'emportent finalement assez
facilement 11 à 4 le deuxième plus gros
score de la saison pour les locaux
deuxième mi temps voilà dès qu'on a
commencé à jouer ça allait mieux quoi le
score pour fait quoi le but c'était de
mettre au maximum se faire plaisir parce
qu'il ya deux de nos joueurs qui s'en
vont quand même dans dans d'autres clubs
pour évoluer à plus haut niveau mais
donc le but c'était de se faire plaisir
entre nous et le maximum de buts
elancourt thème cette saison en milieu
de tableau à la 5e place de la poule sur
huit équipes engagées
un petit peu décevant l'année dernière
va finir l'année au même niveau on
pensait au moins jouer les play off
cette année on a eu quelques petits
problèmes à l'aîné des naissances ou
je vais pas gérer ça ils sont tous papa
on est tous heureux qu'ils soient pas
mes deux meilleures attaques de kampala
objectifs la saison prochaine revenir en
nationale 3 après être descendu de cette
division en 2017